bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic les ondes
prenons une corde lorsqu on agite une
extrémité de la corde un phénomène
étrange se produit les agitations que
l'on imprime à l'extrémité de la corde
semble se propager jusqu'à atteindre
l'autre extrémité
c'est ce mécanisme de propagation dans
l'espace que l'on appelle une onde pour
comprendre comment les agitations se
propage le long de la corde
observant ce qui se passe à l'échelle
des atomes on peut imaginer la corde
comme une longue chaîne qui serait formé
d'atomes successifs
ces atomes interagissent tous avec leurs
voisins un peu comme s'ils étaient
reliés par des ressorts comme dans le
cas de ressort si on essaye de
rapprocher deux atomes
ils vont générer une force répulsive
pour s'éloigner et al'inverse si on
essaye de les éloigner
alors ils vont générer une force
attractive pour se rapprocher
regardons ce qui se passe si l'on
soulève le premier atome de la corde du
fait qu'on l'a déplacé cet atome a été
éloigné de son voisin par conséquent il
va le tirer vers lui comme s'il était
relié par un ressort cependant en tirant
sur son voisin celui ci va se soulever
et ainsi il va à son tour tiré sur
l'atome suivant
de proche en proche les atomes vont
successivement se tirer les uns les
autres et le mouvement que l'on avait
appliqué aux tous premiers atomes va se
propager le long de la corde
en faisant cette expérience on comprend
mieux le phénomène de propagation
lorsqu'on imprime un mouvement à
l'extrémité de la corde on donne de
l'énergie aux tous premiers atomes se
premiers atomes valeur transmettre cette
énergie au second qui va à son tour
transmettre cette énergie à la tome
suivant et ainsi de suite
une onde n'est donc pas le déplacement
d'un objet à proprement parler mais
plutôt la propagation d'une énergie les
ondes présente des caractéristiques
intéressantes par exemple si on fixe une
extrémité de la corde et que l'on envoie
une onde en direction de cette extrémité
l'ong va se réfléchir et repartir dans
l'autre sens comme si elle avait rebondi
contre un obstacle
autre phénomène intéressant si l'on
envoie deux ondes l'une contre l'autre
alors elles vont se superposer
par exemple une bosse plus une bosse au
moment de se croiser vont s'ajouter pour
former une bosse deux fois plus grande
et al'inverse une bosse plus un creux
vont s'annuler
dans notre monde on peut trouver des
ondes à peu près partout certaines zones
se propage selon une dimension le long
d'une ligne comme on l'a vu avec la
corde
d'autres zones se propage sur des
surfaces à deux dimensions
par exemple les vagues à la surface de
l'eau et enfin comme notre espace est à
trois dimensions
il existe des ondes se propageant dans
toutes les directions
c'est par exemple le cas des ondes
sonores toutes ces ondes se propage à
travers des matériaux à travers la corde
la surface de l'eau pour les vagues ou
encore des molécules d'air pour le son
il existe cependant des ondes qui n'ont
besoin d'aucun support matériel pour se
propager par exemple le couplage des
champs électriques et magnétiques
entraîne l'existence de ce qu'on appelle
des ondes électromagnétiques
ces ondes électromagnétiques peuvent se
propager dans le vide
elles n'ont pas besoin d'un support de
matières elles composent la lumière et
les couleurs que l'on voit mais
également les rayons x des ultraviolets
les infrarouges et toute une gamme
d'autres mondes qui sont invisibles à
nos yeux
enfin tous les corps qui possède une
masse déforme l'espace temps cette
déformation de l'espace temps dévie la
trajectoire des objets par exemple la
terre tourne autour du soleil car
celui-ci des formes l'espace temps
autour de lui tout comme les vagues à la
surface de l'eau si l'on pouvait
déplacer très rapidement des objets très
lourd comme par exemple deux trous noirs
il est probable que ceci se mette à
générer des ondes
ces ondes d'espace-temps vont se
propager dans l'univers en le déformant
sur leur passage
c'est ce que l'on appelle des ondes
gravitationnelles